fans were waiting for you over the last
nine months as you took a hiatus
but it's so exciting that the new era of
why don't we is here
so i want to know what happened during
the last nine months
a lot man you know we took our first
break
ever as ben we had been touring for
about three years
and we've only been a band for four
years so there wasn't much time
in between to even really grow as man
yeah so in this time we obviously wrote
an album
uh we wrote all in which is out now and
i can go check it out
[Music]
we finally got to sit down and talk
together and i
asked those bigger questions like who do
we want to really be what do we want to
sound like
what do we want to say you know what's
our message to the world and uh
yeah and i'm really happy with where
we're at together now
with this hiatus that you took you also
took a break from social media and
and being such a a band that has such a
special connection
with your fans where you're constantly
communicating with them through social
media
did you guys really miss that connection
with them i mean yeah
we missed it um but it's funny that you
mention it because
uh by the end of last year i mean we
toured from
beginning of march all the way up until
the 23rd of december it was our last
show of the year
and by the end of that we we actually
saw a lot of our fans
you know tweeting and commenting and
saying like you guys might not know it
but
we think you all need a break y'all have
really been going hard for the past
three years and so we kind of took a
step
and we're like okay do we and then we
were kind of like
maybe maybe we do our fans we saw a lot
of messages and tweets like where are
you guys we miss you so much
and we were like we're coming don't you
worry i think
that nine-month break for fans like me
it was challenging
but you know at the end of the road it's
been such a success we got
fallen which is a song that you wrote
you produced you sing we've got
instruments
how important was it to you guys that in
this new era of why don't we
it is you through and through everything
is done by you
so we all always played instruments and
we always wrote our own music
but you know there's a sort of uh
pressure i feel like in pop music and in
you know this industry where there's
really a high bar set
for music for a long time we just
overthought
the idea of coming out with our own
music because honestly
that's rare today that uh the artists
would go
in and write an album and produce it on
their own and we finally had the time
and
we're more than happy with what came out
what inspired you guys during the
writing process what life experiences
did you go through
that made you feel compelled to grab a
pen and paper and be like i gotta get
this out through my music
i mean we just wrote from our our
stories in our life going on
fans want to know about sort of our
relationships and
things going on in our personal life and
if you want to know about that
you should just listen to this album
because everything's in there
[Music]
yeah we're super honest and it comes
directly from
our hearts and what's going on in our
lives and i think
being in quarantine actually made this
album
more special because when you're kind of
stuck in your house all day bored out of
your mind you have a lot
uh you have a lot to think about and i
think that's inspired more thoughts than
we thought it would honestly and so
you know in a weird way the album was
kind of therapeutic where you know you
can just
write down just about any thought you
had throughout the day and uh
yeah so a lot of different uh thoughts
and emotions
so jonah you obviously just teased that
love will be a theme on the album what
are some other themes or words that you
can use to describe
what we're going to be listening to we
have a song about anxiety
on the album um kind of just
honest about stuff that we deal with we
have a song about i guess just
like having fun good times there's one
that we wrote
specifically to be like the last song
that we perform in the show on tour
okay wait does that mean it's like an
emotional moment we'll all be holding
each other or
is it like big energy we'll all be
holding hands and days
yeah a little bit of vote it's an
all-encompassing song of just
you know wishing a night would never end
wow and that's how we feel when we go to
your shows truly
whenever you post a photo of little
lavender our heart kind of just like
melts into
a million pieces how does she inspire
your writing your musical process
all of that i mean so much you know
every time i go and see her
i always have more ideas to write like
literally
the other day i went to hawaii and i
instantly
like you know just feeling emotions from
the lab
you know you fall more in love with her
every day so i started writing a song
just
right when i was there he came back and
and sang it for us actually and it was
it was really beautiful i know she's
very young but
do you ever play her your music and what
is it like to see her reaction
oh totally it was funny i ended up i
showed her the music video before it
came out actually
and each time i would pop on the screen
do you know like do you know like what
our favorite songs are like you see it
in their face
that's a good question i can't say
[Music]
i mean you guys all just kind of lit up
when i mentioned lavender does anyone
else have baby fever as a result of
spending time with her
i mean i got i got a cat so that's
that's surprising for now
jack's always sending videos i was
laughing in the chat and every time he
does we're like oh my god
wow like we're all we're all her uncles
like we're like extended
yeah yeah i think we all know i'm the
best i want to talk about falling i
heard a little white claw was involved
in the making of this song tell me what
happened there yeah yeah um
so the day that we wrote it we were
actually going to work on another song
on the album that day and daniel pulled
up
uh and had this melody that popped into
his head on the way to the studio and
was like yo
guys uh what do you think of this like i
think we should write it right now
jack happened to walk in with a huge
thing of white claws
mango white claws and so
when daniel was first making the beat he
titled it the mango white claw beat
well like to this day if you go on his
on his laptop it's still called
yeah how many white claw does it take to
get to the level of creating fallen
honestly i feel like more than three and
you're not gonna have a song like
following you're gonna have a
terrible yeah another thing i really
love about the group
is that you guys all let each other
shine as individuals and you know my era
growing up a lot of the bands it was
like there's one lead singer there's two
lead singers i feel like
whenever you watch a wide opening
project especially fallen
you all have your moment so i'm curious
was this a conversation that you guys
had early on and how do you decide
who's going to sing which parts now i
think that stemmed from us being solo
artists beforehand
and we came into it with a lot of
respect for each other right away and
when we're writing a song even like i'll
i'll hear apart and be like oh my god
zach is going to just murder that yeah
yeah yeah like even though
the hook for fallen right away we knew
was zack's part and
when zach heard it he's like that sounds
like my part
yeah and it wasn't even some weird like
you get the hook bro come on it was
like bro you better take that hook right
yeah wow i like that
after four years of recording music it's
it's become pretty easy
to kind of tell like whose five is what
and where they can go i mean sometimes
we run into
little bits where we're like you know
maybe two of us should try this one part
and let's see you know how it sounds
and yeah it happened on fallen i i
started with cutting the pre
though and it just didn't work out for
me i was like i don't love it here
i don't love this spot daniel on the
demo killed it so we were like yeah just
take that
and then i tried verse two and it worked
out and then uh
yeah so it's a really cool process i
think there's definitely something to be
said for
like when you build other people up you
never
fail to also be successful i think
there's
different ways to look at at life and
like some people
might go about it in like selfish ways
and i think we've never really done that
we always just want to see each other
succeed and
be there because we're good friends the
other thing that fans are kind of going
wild over is
this uh reinvention of some of your
looks
everybody has kind of rocked some new
hair or something different
but the fans want to know zack um why
did you abstain from making uh a big
look reinvention i don't know i'm not
trying to change my hair right now
i think if you look at my hair from the
start of the band to now it's it's just
made a big difference slowly i think i'm
not
the type of person to drastically just
change my hair
i was thinking about maybe highlighting
it and then i was like yeah
i'm not gonna do it i'm sticking with my
hair but i don't know
when you got here honestly for me
it was just quarantine i was drawing my
hair i didn't have
a way to cut my hair and then it got to
be when we're coming back and i'm like
oh my hair is long
i guess rock it
for me it was just like i was blonde for
four years i just felt like the right
move would be to go and try dark hair
and see how it worked out and uh
it's worked out so far yeah i love
having blonde hair i
i just got bored i guess and i actually
have pink hair at one point i just
in one of them quarantines and i just
was like
i'm gonna go bond and now i'm still gone
have you adjusted at this point to being
so loved what is it like being a
heartthrob
it's definitely a one-of-a-kind thing i
would say it's uh
i you know i really can't complain i
mean as it doesn't
suck
being you know a teenager and then now
into our early 20s it's
it's definitely not a bad thing to have
you know girls screaming for you and
chasing you down the street we missed
dreams though we haven't heard him in a
minute
so we're uh we're itching to get back
out on the road as soon as we can
corbin you just said you know you guys
have been doing this for
you know a few years at this point who
is the best with fame and who kind of
dislikes fame the most
there's different aspects of it that i
like and that i don't like
um like what i mean there's there's ups
and downs with everything yeah yeah
everything yeah i mean i'll be honest
like lately more than ever
i think quarantine made it worse for me
but i was struggling a lot with
coming home after being on tour and
seeing
friends i'd have my whole life look at
me different
and it was a weird thing where i feel
like fame
heightens another person's insecurity
and kind of
they reflect their insecurity right back
to you which is just weird
and they can't really help it but having
to
deal with that and you know for a while
it felt like maybe i just shouldn't
like start a conversation because i
don't want to make them feel
you know nervous to talk to me that was
weird but um i think
we've all been really good at handling
it together too like i'll just be real
with the guys
before i'm real with anyone else and
tell them how i'm feeling and we're
usually in the same boat one of the
biggest things for me is kind of just
questioning people's
intentions when you first meet them it's
like especially in
los angeles like there's a lot of
awesome people out here there's also
some people who are sort of social
climbers and
might just use you for what they can
gain and then not talk to you anymore
and that kind of a thing so um i don't
know
i i think that sometimes i overthink
things and like
i'll come into a conversation and they
obviously have like a
preconceived idea of who i might be and
i want to come off like that person and
then i'm like wait no i'm just i'm just
thinking
i don't know it's a it's a definite like
psychological trip first
for sure it's weird definitely more ups
and downs
yeah we get to travel music for a living
we get to hang out all the time like
it's it's really really at the end of
the day too we're doing what we love you
know
jonah you just kind of mentioned like
it's it's challenging at times you don't
ever really know what people's
intentions are and
everybody is always curious you know are
they dating anybody who are they dating
can we do a quick little relationship
roundup and i'm curious how it's been
dating when you guys have such a
high public profile that is one of those
things that we just love to keep
personal
you know because yeah there's only a
select few things
there's not many things at this point in
our life so we can keep personal
and so even for the sake of the
relationship it makes it so much easier
when we can just you know be normal
together
but i am single
okay can can everyone else confirm
you have to listen to the albums with
this new era of why don't we i truly
feel like the best is yet to come
do you guys have an idea of where you
want to be
in five or ten years i mean are these
conversations that you have together
as a group whether it's i want you know
xyz
album sold i want five grammys the main
like goal for us is just to like impact
as many people
in the world uh whatever
that looks like um but obviously we have
specific goals
and stuff as well like i can't wait for
the day that we go on an arena tour
top five billboard win five grammys like
you said
there's like old voice memos of us like
talking to our future self yeah we
literally made a voice memo we're like
dear future self like
i hope that you've done this stuff why i
release those kind of crazy that would
be crazy
you